Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and couple really
important bits of Doctor Who news, this video
is a breakdown of all the series 8 episodes
straight from the horse’s mouth, Steven
Moffat did a short synopsis for each of the
12 regular episodes. And everybody cheer because
the BBC is bringing back Doctor Who Confidential
as a webseries. Inside the UK it will be exclusive
to the iPlayer.
No official word if it will be made available
on youtube or elsewhere in the United States
or other countries.
Just to explain. If you remember when the
50th Anniversary aired and they posted all
those behind the scenes videos. It’s going
to be just like that. The Confidential episodes
will be available immediately after episodes
air. And when I say that I mean right after
episodes air on BBC One. So this Saturday
the 23rd. Doctor Who Episode 1 runs from 7:50PM
GMT to 9:10. It’s 80 minutes. So you’ll
be able to watch Confidential episode 1 at
9:10.
They just announced this so BBC America hasn’t
said whether they’ll run the shorts but
even if they don’t I’ll still try to include
any cool info from them in my videos week
to week.
Which reminds me, new giveaway starts right
now, all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
Now here is the master episode schedule with
official synopsis from Steven Moffat. These
are just the regular episodes, it doesn’t
include information on the Christmas Special.
I’m just going to run these as a montage.
Episode 1 - Deep Breath
Airdate Aug 23
"Who frowned me this face?"
A slaughterhouse restaurant and a buried spaceship
lead The Doctor into a confrontation with
a long-forgotten foe...
Episode 2 - Into The Dalek
Airdate Aug 30
"Imagine the worst thing in the universe,
and then don't bother because you're looking
at right now. This is evil refined as engineering."
Episode 3 - Robot of Sherwood
Airdate Sept 6
"There's no such thing as Robin Hood!"
In a sun-dappled Sherwood Forest, The Doctor
discovers an evil plan from beyond the stars.
But with of Nottingham at stake (and possibly
Derby), there's no time for the two adventurers
to get into a fight about who is real and
who isn't - which is probably why they do
very little else!
Episode 4 - Listen
Airdate Sept 13
"What's that in the mirror, and the corner
of your eye? What's the footstep following,
but never passing by?"
What scares the grand old man of time? What
horrors lurk under his bed? Ghosts of the
past and future crowd into the lives of The
Doctor and Clara; a terrified caretaker in
a children's home, the last man standing in
the universe, and a little boy who doesn't
want to join the army...
Episode 5 - Time Heist
Airdate Sept 20
"Welcome to the bank of Karabraxos."
The Bank of Karabraxos is the deadliest bank
in the cosmos - only a fool or genius would
tempt to rob it. Fortunately, for The Doctor,
he's both. But nothing even The Doctor has
encountered can prepare them for the Teller:
a creature of terrifying power that can detect
guilt.
Episode 6 - The Caretaker
Airdate Sept 27
"Human beings have incredibly short life-spans.
Frankly, you should all be in a permanent
state of panic. Tick tock, tick tock."
Clara has it all under control: her life at
school, her life in space; her new boyfriend
and her mad old Time Lord. Everything is humming
along just fine, so long as everybody never
actually meets. And then, one morning, just
before assembly, Coal Hill welcomes a new
relief caretaker with a Scottish accent.
Episode 7 - Kill The Moon
Airdate Oct 4
"The little planetoid that's been tagging
along beside you for a hundred years, which
gives you light at night and seas to sail,
is in the process of falling to bits."
In the near future, The Doctor and Clara arrive
on a decrepit shuttle making a suicide mission
to the Moon. Crashing on the lunar surface,
they find a mining base full of eviscerated
corpses, spider-like creatures scuttling about
in the dark, and a terrible dilemma.
speeding among the stars of the future, a
legend is stalking the passengers. Once you
see the Mummy, you have 66 seconds to live.
Clara sees The Doctor at his most deadliest
and most ruthless - and finally she realises
she's made the right decision. Because this
is their last adventure: it's time to say
goodbye to the Time Lord.
do you hide when event the walls are no protection.
"D'you like the forest being in Trafalgar
Square? I think it's lovely."
One morning in London, and every city and
town in the world, the human race wakes up
to the most surprising invasion yet: the trees
have moved back in. Everywhere, in every land,
a forest has grown overnight and taken back
the Earth.
Episode 11 and 12 Dark Water & Death In Heaven
Two-Parter
Airdate Nov 1
"You betrayed me. You betrayed my trust, our
friendship, and everything I've ever stood
Some of those later airdates are subject to
change but the big difference from the Matt
with the story even if they miss any episodes.
In case you haven’t seen my previous videos
the weekly giveaways will start when I post
each episode review saturday nights. All you
have to do to enter those is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the videos.
I’ll be posting bonus videos before episodes
air saturday mornings and then sunday morning
I’ll do Q&A videos where I’ll announce
who won.
My next bonus video will be my favorite catch
phrases, I’ll post that tomorrow. This saturday
I’m going to post my review of episode 1
earlier than normal but I will have spoiler
warnings. I might live tweet the episode.
So if you want to have some fun you can follow
me at @awesomemergency
My facebook is still facebook/ emergency awesome
Right now click here to learn about which
episodes I think you should check out before
Series 8 and click here for classic episodes
to check out.
Thank you so much for watching, I’ll see
you guys tonight. High Fives!